KALYAN REDDY: Welcome to Apps
Script Crash Course.
My name is Kalyan Reddy,
and this is my
co-worker, Arun Nagarajan.
And today, we're going to be
talking about ScriptDb.
We're going to be taking a deep
dive into some of the
features to tell you all about
the different areas that you
can focus in and show
you some examples.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So what I would like to do is
start off with just some
introductory slides, kind
of set the stage.
show a little bit about what
the context of ScriptDb is.
Then we'll look at some of the
tutorials we already have,
highlight some of the important
things that you
should know.
And we'll show some
of the important
documentation elements.
And then, we'll get into the
script editor and start
writing some interesting
examples, and then maybe even
look at some other things you
can do with ScriptDb.
Sound good?
KALYAN REDDY: Sounds good.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
So let me just kick off things
on my presentation here.
So ScriptDb was originally
announced at Google I/O last
year, in 2012.
So it's less than a year old.
But it's actually getting a
good amount of feature set
that it has, and you
can do a lot of
interesting things with it.
So it's a JavaScript
Object database.
So what you're able to do is
just take native JavaScript
Objects and dump it right
into this database,
which is really powerful.
Every script project gets
its own database.
So you're able to have a scope
that is wide to the entire
script that you have.
So multiple users can share
the same database.
You can actually segment out
data by having multiple
different properties for
different users.
But it's kind of scoped
at the script level.
The API, I think, will be
extremely simple and
straightforward to use, as
you'll see for Create, Read,
Update, Deletes, and
things like that.
And the paradigm be very
similar to other NoSQL
databases that you
may be used to.
KALYAN REDDY: Can you an example
of a NoSQL database,
or how that differs?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So NoSQL is not an official term
or anything like that.
But it's something that people
have started to use as far as
when something is
non-relational.
There's actually a really good
Wikipedia page on it.
I highly recommend it.
A lot of good examples in here
about what a NoSQL database
is, what the different types
of them are, object store,
graph stores, key
value stores.
We're more on the document
store level of things.
But a popular one is
MongoDB, CouchDB.
There really is quite
a few variations
of these NoSQL databases.
And the idea is that you're
programming, and you're
working with objects in most
programming languages.
And you want to be able to
just take that object and
store it, rather than have to
convert that into a relational
data set and save it.
So that's the idea behind
NoSQL databases.
KALYAN REDDY: I can see how it
would be simpler to use and
potentially more powerful.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So it kind of takes away the
normalization, denormalization
of an object from a database
to a programming
layer, and then back.
So it saves you that overhead.
But it is sort of a newer
phenomenon, so a lot of
people, when they come to a
NoSQL data store, they're
looking for, wait, how
do I do joins?
How do I do updates?
Things like that.
So it is a little bit
of a learning curve.
But I think it's a
very short curve.
And a lot of different
technology is going that way.
So it's a very useful thing.
One of the first things that
folks have to get used to is,
what is an object?
So in JavaScript, that's sort
of a nebulous thing.
It's not really known to be an
object-oriented language.
But there are certainly
objects in JavaScript.
So you're able to do a lot of
interesting things here, where
you can have what's called
a JavaScript Map Object.
So this example here
is an object.
So that's employee data.
It has a type property.
You can see that it's got an
employee ID, which is a
numeric value.
It's got a few strings.
Names, department IDs,
also numeric.
So that is an object.
So this is a map we call,
name and value.
What are not objects are things
like just a number.
A string.
Even an array itself is not a
map object that you can sort
into ScriptDb.
So that's important.
A lot of folks try to just
say, OK, I have an array.
I wanted to store it.
Can I just dump it
into ScriptDb?
Well, you have to structure it
in a way that looks and feels
like a map object.
So that's important.
So let's take a look at a
couple examples here.
And we'll come back to that, and
we'll actually run these
so that you get a sense for
how that looks and feels.
But here's a very simple example
of taking that object
that we showed and being able to
store that into a database.
So you store it as db.save.
So this is sort of the
reference, ScriptDb. getMyDb.
So you'll see that line
very frequently in
all ScriptDb examples.
And what that basically gets you
is the reference for the
current projects, ScriptDb.
And you can just say .save,
and it saves the object.
And then you can actually
retrieve the
ID if you care for.
KALYAN REDDY: So just to
clarify, we're not
specifically formatting
or modifying the
object in any way.
It just the original object
that we constructed?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Precisely.
So once you have an object that
you like the shape of,
and you're able to pass it
around to different functions
that you have, or do other
things with it, then you stop
worrying about, OK,
can is this an
appropriate mode to store?
You don't have to worry about
even having a unique number of
properties for every object.
So I can add a new property
here for a new object for
manager and not worry about
existing objects.
So that's a really nice thing
too, is that your ScriptDb can
be very heterogeneous.
So you can have five employees
without a manager.
And you decide that out of
policy, new employees need to
have a manager property.
And then you can
go and do that.
In relational databases, you
have to alter your schema, and
you have to say, this now
has a default of null,
and things like that.
Nothing to worry about
like that.
KALYAN REDDY: Reduce the
overhead and the complexity.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly.
So it just kind of makes it very
agile, and you can start
storing things very quickly,
without having to worry about
the sort of schema, which
is very rigid
in relational databases.
And had a lot of experience
with that.
And I can say that there's
a time and place for it.
But for most things in Apps
Script, I would not
really go that way.
Great.
So let's take a look at--
so we saved it.
How do you retrieve it?
The querying syntax
is actually super
straightforward.
So again, you get the
database reference.
And the querying syntax
is basically also
an object by itself.
And you query by example.
So essentially, you specify a
subset of the properties that
you want to filter it by.
So in this case, I'm trying to
retrieve all employees with
the employee ID of one.
And if this has any matches,
it'll return iterator.
So iterator is a concept
that basically
fetches as you go along.
So it optimizes the
fetch times.
So you don't try to load
everything up front.
You actually get a reference to
what's called an iterator.
And then you can say, well,
it's got more, keep
giving it to me.
So it kind of optimizes the
underlying implementation
rather than you having to wait
for the whole results set to
be aggregated and collected into
a single collection that
you can immediately start
operating on.
This allows you to do things
like, well, if I find the
object I care for, well, let
me just get out of it.
I don't care for the
whole results sent
back from the disk.
KALYAN REDDY: OK.
So you can just break
out of that loop.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly.
So the iterator concept is
actually quite popular in Java
and other programming languages
which may have seen.
So here's how you get it.
I got the object.
And then notice that it's
immediately an object.
So I don't have to say,
JSON.stringify, or JSON.parse,
or anything like that.
You actually get an actual
object, and I can just start
doing the dot notation
on it to get the
properties I care for.
So I can say current.firstname,
current.lastname.
And I could go along.
So it's quite powerful
in that regard.
KALYAN REDDY: And we were
talking about the
heterogeneous objects before.
Querying something, for example,
employee ID one.
It'll get both types if you
have multiple types.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yes, if I have two objects with
employee ID one by some
reason, one of them has a
manager, another one doesn't
have a manager, I'll get
both of them back.
So it doesn't have to be
a particular type.
So ScriptDb is not the only
way you can store
data in Apps Script.
There's actually quite
a few ways.
And there was actually great
session at Google I/O last
year, where we talked about all
the different mechanisms.
Just to highlight some of the
important ones, JDBC.
So if you have a relational
database already with lots of
data in it, you may want to
to continue using that.
Or if you have a lot of data
that you want to be able to
access from other systems
outside of Apps Script, then
JDBC make sense.
Spreadsheets are super
lightweight.
They have a UI, a tabular
UI to go with.
So it's great.
However, for querying, there's
no such syntax of being able
to say, give me all rows where
employee ID is one.
Right?
So that's not so nice
about spreadsheets.
You can actually store
it in files.
So drive API, the docs list API,
allows you to store and
retrieve files and content
of a file pretty quickly.
But again, not really
structured, so you
can work with it.
A couple of name value pair
type storage systems.
ScriptProperties and
UserProperties, which is good
for things like session IDs,
some lightweight preferences,
and things like that.
And then, you can actually
decide to make calls out to
external API to store things.
Just like JDBC, you
may want to use--
App Engine has this concept
that we're working on
releasing, which is in limited
products to test right now.
We announced it at I/O
last year as well.
Called Cloud Endpoints.
So you can actually publish an
API, a rest API, where I can
send up data and get storage
on the server side there.
Again, those are the
different options.
But I think ScriptDb is sort
of the baked in one that is
the easiest to get started.
KALYAN REDDY: What are some
advantages, let's say, versus
using it on a spreadsheet?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So I think my
favorite thing is that--
and a lot of people prefer
spreadsheets
because it's got a UI.
Right?
But as I'll show in a little,
you can actually solve that.
You can actually kind of decide
that you want to build
a little UI yourself.
So people oftentimes gravitate
towards storing things in a
spreadsheet, because I can
easily edit it, or I can
easily visualize it.
But we can work around that.
The querying is I think the
biggest reason that I would
prefer ScriptDb.
You can actually build very
complex queries with sorts,
with between operators, with
multiple conditions, and get
the exact record you care
for as an object.
Rather than in a spreadsheet,
you get, it's essentially a
dumb table in some ways.
And you have to iterate through
it and find the rows
you care for, which
is not so great.
So there are a lot of resources
we have on ScriptDb.
I'll just kind of quickly walk
through some of the tutorials
that we have.
So if you go to our developer
page, developers.googl
e.com/apps-script, and then
ScriptDb, one word, it's
actually a really
good tutorial.
And when I was new to the
team, this was actually
extremely helpful, where I was
able to get a very quick lay
the land of all things
ScriptDb-related.
So it's actually pretty
well-organized as well.
So how do you save data?
How do you modify data?
How do you do things
like deleting?
Querying the database,
comparison operators.
And we'll actually kind of look
at a few of these things.
Some really good examples
that you can copy and
paste and get going.
Let me point out a couple of
pretty interesting ones.
So here's an interesting one.
So you can see that in this
query right here, we're doing
db.query, address, any
of these objects.
So you can say, give me results
where the adverse
object, which itself is a
composite object, is Jackson,
Mississippi or New
York, New York.
KALYAN REDDY: OK.
So basically, we saw an example
of a query, where we
gave it multiple different
objects.
It's like, give me something
with employ ID one, and match
it with something else that
has the same thing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
Exactly.
And it can actually
go further, where
it's not just inclusive.
It can say exclusive as well,
and not in type scenario.
So really a lot of the semantics
of what you can do
with SQL with where
in, where not in.
Things like that, you're able to
do pretty quickly with the
ScriptDb syntax as well.
So you can say, not Texas
in this case.
And we have a pretty robust
set of comparison
operators as well.
So it's not just literal
matches.
You could say numeric
comparisons.
So you can say, greater than
21, between 13 and 20.
So quite a pretty robust
set of things there.
Sorting and paging.
So pagination is something that
you end up with, you have
to deal with, when you have
just hundreds of rows,
thousand of rows.
In a lot of cases, you
may have reached the
limit, which is 50,000.
Right?
So you have to worry about
making sure that you get the
right set back in
the beginning.
So sorting becomes
very important.
Show the most relevant
data first.
But then, if the user cares for
more, you can hit the Next
button and have that called back
to the server, and then
fetch the next 100 items.
KALYAN REDDY: And even if your
initial query returns a lot of
results, you might not want
them all at the same time.
We give you a certain number,
and if you want more, you can
paginate that query as well.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
Yeah.
And another thing that I like
about this tutorial is that it
kind of talks about, how
do you apply ScriptDb?
So a lot of folks, like I
mention, are coming from a
relational database world.
So this actually talks about,
well, how would tables
translate in ScriptDb?
Right?
How do you deal with things
like transactions?
This is something that we have
talked about a little bit,
which is that in a multi-user
scenario, if you're using
ScriptDb, by itself, it's
not guaranteed to be
transactional.
By itself, it's not guaranteed
to be atomic.
You have to bake
some things in.
Just say, OK, for this
particular time period, you
get the lock.
We have a very robust service
called LockService.
You're able to get the lock,
write the object you want to,
and then release the lock.
And then the next
item comes in.
The same applies for deletes
and updates as well.
So it's actually quite a
powerful way to do the
transactions in the way you
care for, with the timeout
settings you care for, rather
than just inherent, built-in
versions, which may not be
appropriate for all scenarios.
KALYAN REDDY: So it's a great
way to take two simple
services that we offer
and combine them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
Exactly.
Yeah, the lock service, actually
I think underneath
the covers, is quite a
technological thing that we
offer that really makes these
sort of distributed apps very
easy to build.
One thing to note is dates.
So we don't store
dates natively.
You have to tell us what
time zone it's in.
You have to tell us how
you want to store it.
The simplest would be just to
get time, which will get the
milliseconds [INAUDIBLE], which
may not be appropriate
for you to retrieve back.
But since JSON doesn't support
dates natively, we have to
force you to tell us,
OK, what time zone?
What properties about it
do you want to store?
You can sort as a numerical
value, or as a
string value as well.
So that's something that trips
up some people that I think is
important to understand.
What else is relevant here
that I think is quite
interesting?
You have a few recipes here
about, how do you copy a
ScriptDb data from a spreadsheet
to a ScriptDb, and
then vice versa?
So I think that's
pretty useful.
If you start off with a bunch
of starter data in a
spreadsheet, you can end up in
a ScriptDb very quickly.
And a couple of things here.
So here's another section that
I think is relevant, and then
we'll jump off from
the tutorial.
How do you compare it
with other systems?
So Inserts, Updates,
Delete, Queries.
These are things that
you're use to.
And these are rather than SQL,
and MySQL, or Oracle, or some
other system that you
may be used to.
And there are comparisons to how
it relates to our world.
So again, I think it's
pretty useful.
All right.
Great.
So there's some quota items as
well towards the bottom.
So definitely look at that to
understand what some of the
heuristics are for your
particular account type.
So certainly, think
through that.
But I see that for the most
case, since we're destroying
text, it's extremely efficient,
fast, lightweight,
that I'm not really worried
about quota for most things
that I'm working on.
And the documentation
itself is actually
fairly robust as well.
And I'll put a plug
for that as well.
So hopefully, that kind of gives
you a couple of things
that I think are relevant to
understand and keep track of.
KALYAN REDDY: Great.
So you mentioned earlier that
you could use one ScriptDb in
a multi-user situation.
And you said it's tied
to a project.
So can you clarify that
a little bit?
Is that tied in with libraries
and anywhere?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
So let's say that you may have
a particular app that one
interface is a web app, another
interface might be a
spreadsheet, or a trigger
somewhere.
Right?
But you may want the users to
operate on the same data, or
make that available
across the board.
So the way you would do
that is a library.
The library has an instance
of a database.
Every project has its own
instance of a database.
We allow for you to pass in the
database to the caller, or
have the caller pass in its
database into the library.
KALYAN REDDY: OK.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So that's how
you can actually share the
data between multiple projects,
is using libraries.
So it can actually kind of share
data in a very robust
way, either have one copy that
is the master copy, or have
the children send up its
copy to a parent.
And things like that.
KALYAN REDDY: Very cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So it's some
good recipes around there in
our tutorials as well.
So what I'll do now is I'll
actually do a couple of
examples of how this
looks and feels.
So I'm just going to copy the
examples that I started with.
I'm going to copy this guy.
Come out of the window, and go
to our trusted script editor.
I'm just going to start with
the blank project.
OK.
So I'm just going to
paste that in.
Save it as ScriptDb demo.
And there it is.
So it's a very simple
function.
Just going to create an
object and store it.
So I'm going to run it.
So ScriptDb, since it is
metered, we have to have you
authorize it.
Very quick process, similar to
other things that we have.
You go through that.
And that's it.
So it ran.
We're not doing any UI
here, so I have to
go to View and Logs.
And you can see that the
ID is logged here.
And one thing about this
ScriptDb is that by itself, it
has no sort of ID or unique
key that it provides other
than this Get ID special
function.
So if I run this again, it's
hard to see here, but you
really have a different ID that
comes back, which means
that there are two copies
of this employee.
KALYAN REDDY: OK.
So this ID is for one specific
object that she stores.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
One instance.
So since this instance is
reinitialized, so employee
data got reinitialized, that's
a whole new object as far as
ScriptDb's concerned.
If I pass this around, it'll
be the same instance.
But it's an entirely
different instance.
Oops.
Apologize for that.
Reminder came back up.
OK.
Great.
So let's kind of jump in here to
another function, which is
the reading of data.
So this--
let's go in here.
Create a new method called
loadEmployee.
And I'll do something
interesting just to let you
know that this is a pattern
that you'll see a lot.
So I'll just copy the
relevant function.
Or variable rather.
So I'll just have one variable
called Db that I'll use in
both functions, rather than
me having to recall that.
Same effect, but I think it
helps you go through it.
So I'm going to now query it.
How many results do you
expect here, Kalyan?
KALYAN REDDY: I expect two.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good.
You're paying attention.
I'm going to run it.
And what it's doing is
very straightforward.
Its just going to query
an employee ID.
Then it's going to loop through
it using that iterator
that I talked about, hasNext.
Essentially, that's a Boolean.
That's essentially doing
while true type thing.
And I can just go take a
look at the execution--
oops, not that.
Take a look at the logs.
And I see two John
Testingtons.
Good sample name, I think.
So that's actually pretty
useful, right?
So you're able to very quickly
see how do you store an
object, and how do
you retrieve it?
But this could get
a little clumsy.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, it seems
like having to use the logs as
an interface.
It's not really clear what
it actually looks
like within the ScriptDb.
Is there a way to
clarify that?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So today, we don't really
have a great
built-in console for ScriptDb.
However, we provide, like I said
before, a very robust set
of APIs, where if you're
interested and if you're
willing, you can actually build
your own console for
your instance.
And to kind of aid that,
I've actually started
a very simple project.
And I'll actually go to my
GitHub project in my repo.
And you can see that I've
started this little thing
called ScriptDb Visualizer.
And the whole idea is that you
can copy and paste this very
quickly and get started
for your own instance
that you may have.
So what I'm going to do is just
copy the code here, go to
Raw, copy this guy.
Go back here.
Trying to paste this guy here.
And let me just make sure that
there's no conflicts.
The only thing is, I realize
that I have two getDbs.
So I'm just going
to ignore that.
You can see that it's going
to publish as a web app.
And there's an HTML file that
I need to pull down as well.
I'll go back here.
KALYAN REDDY: So you built this
using our HTML service?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
So it's actually a really good
example for our HTML service
as well, which we'll talk
about in a little bit.
So I've got a new HTML file.
I think I called it
ScriptDbConsole.
And then I'll just
paste that in.
Let's see.
I think I mistyped
this guy here.
I'm moving too fast.
All right.
Cool.
So ScriptDbConsole.html.
I'll dive in to what's
in here.
This is all put together
in a couple hours.
So certainly, a lot of
room for improvement.
I would love for the community
to get involved and build
something pretty reusable
and great out of this.
So now, what I'll do--
so here's a couple functions
that we're playing with.
Right, Kalyan?
So we're going to now basically
build a little
visualizer for what's
in the database.
And actually, I found out that
it's a great way to kind of
practice your ScriptDb skills.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
At first, it's not readily
apparent what's in there.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So I can then publish
it as a web app.
And for now, I'll just publish
it for myself.
If you're publishing it out for
the world, just make sure
that your ScriptDb is restricted
to yourself through
checking the current users'
email address and comparing it
to a known list.
That way, you're not exposing
data for everybody.
I believe--
let me just run this guy once.
I have a logger example there.
So I'm going to refresh
this guy.
So this is it.
Really Spartan.
But a really simple way to type
in a query, and then see
what's in there.
So here's the query
that says--
hopefully you can see that.
Just an open curly brace and
an end curly brace to say,
give me everything.
So I can just say, Get Count.
KALYAN REDDY: That's
because you're
not specifying anything.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
It means star in relational
databases.
So current count is two.
I can then say, Run the Query.
So I won't actually
see the objects.
It'll show me a nicely formatted
version of the
objects that I care for.
KALYAN REDDY: So those are the
two that we just added.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly.
And you can see that the
IDs are different.
And I could actually create
new objects too.
So I kind of cheated
and created a
couple ahead of time.
So I'll just go ahead and type
in a new object here.
Save this guy.
OK.
So I don't have to go to
the Script Editor.
And today, you're required
to save one by one.
But obviously, you can
save this guy.
And then also, save
the last guy here.
And so I have now a few
employees in my system.
And now, if I do Get Count, what
do you expect, Kalyan?
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
What do we?
2 plus 40?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Ah, so
first of all, I ran
count for this object.
I don't want that.
KALYAN REDDY: Ah, you're query
was a specific object.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
So let me run the count here.
And it's five.
Right?
And then I can run the query.
And I can see the five
employees in it.
John Testington, Arun, Kalyan,
Eric, and then the other John
Testington.
KALYAN REDDY: Gotcha.
The two original ones and the
three you just added.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And it's actually pretty cool
that I can then also
go ahead and query.
So I can say, show me
everybody that has a
department--
I had to put quotes in there.
ID of, I think 14, is what I
had used for most of them,
except for--
I think I used 14 across
the board.
Cool.
So let me just find some
other example.
Maybe employee ID is one.
Just to kind of filter
things out.
Run this query.
And I should get
two items back.
So you can see the double
headers, double lines, kind of
separate out a query run.
So it's kind of useful to
be able to do that.
KALYAN REDDY: Now what if we
wanted to pull up my records
specifically?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So let's filter you by your last
name, and run a query.
And there you are.
KALYAN REDDY: Very cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And let's
actually go ahead and do a
couple of things here.
So one of the things that
we allow you to do is
load by ID in here.
So if you just pasted an ID,
you can just run that, and
then get your object
back as well.
So you don't have to know a
particular property about you.
You can just kind of filter by
IDs as well, which is I think
quite powerful.
And you can pass in multiple
IDs, so I can just comma
delimit here and say load
by ID, and I'll get two
objects back here.
KALYAN REDDY: So if you're
writing a script, you could
keep track of the things
you save by their IDs?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So you don't necessarily need
to know some queryable
attribute about an object,
other than its ID.
So it's actually kind
of powerful.
What you could also do is start
deleting certain things.
So I can say, show me
everybody with the
first name of John.
So one thing you'll realize is
that the Count, Query, and
Delete syntax are
pretty similar.
So you're essentially
passing in a--
so if I just say Get Count,
that should return two.
So two people in there with
the first name of John.
I can just see who they are.
These two people.
Same exact object, but different
IDs, like we know.
We insert them twice.
And I can just hit Delete.
And now if I say Run Query,
no one there for that.
So it's actually kind of cool
that the same kind of query,
the query by example syntax
here, works for getting the
count for that, getting
responses to actual objects,
and then also deleting.
KALYAN REDDY: Very cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you
can query by example.
You can load and delete
by IDs as well.
In order to get count,
you do have to pass
in an actual syntax.
KALYAN REDDY: I see.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK?
And like I said, the actual
syntax to search by
itself is an object.
So I could just hit Save, and
that object will get saved.
And if I now get objects for
everybody, and this will kind
of show the heterogeneous
aspect of it--
I think I saved the
empty object.
So you can see that there's
me, you, just
John, that we saved.
And then, also an empty object,
which was my mistake.
But it's there.
And I can just go ahead and
delete that as well.
So I can just say,
delete that guy.
And now if I run the query
for everybody.
So it's pretty lightweight
console.
It's not meant to
be super fancy.
KALYAN REDDY: It really
helps you visualize
these things, though.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
Let's you see what's in there.
And you can see that
it's really fast.
And a lot of the time is
actually spent in the back and
forth, rather than retrieving
something from the database.
And we started out with the real
simple example here from
the sample slides that I had.
We dropped in the code from
my GitHub account.
And then, off you go.
KALYAN REDDY: Great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And just to give you a sense
for what the code is like,
it's all HTML service.
It does some interesting
things.
It's highlighting some JSON,
using some of the things that
I found on a sample site.
And it just uses the
google.script.run syntax quite
heavily, and uses jQuery
to have the click
handle work on those.
And that's really it.
It just kind of adds
a console prepense
content into your DOM.
And here are the buttons
and the rows in there.
KALYAN REDDY: So you should be
able to, as it is, do most
things with it, right?
Like, we didn't see an example
specifically of updating a
previous record, but you should
be able to get the ID,
and then update it?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You should be
able to update it like that.
It would be great to be able to
upload or insert multiple
objects at once.
And it would be cool to be able
to store certain queries
so you can replay it.
And a lot of useful things
can be built out of this.
And it's a playground
to practice.
And hopefully, this is a good
thing that you can start
building some useful
tools with.
KALYAN REDDY: It's a good
springboard that hopefully,
some of our users will
take and run with.
See what happens.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
Yeah.
So that's really all I had.
Hopefully, this all made
sense and was useful.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah,
thanks a lot.
It was great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank
you very much.
KALYAN REDDY: And thank
you for watching.